pas le temps d'attendre il fallait agir
immédiatement dès le début de l'épidémie
la mairie du 4e arrondissement de paris
a pris les devants le maire a trouvé une
nouvelle mission pour ses locaux
inoccupés
ils ont été mis à disposition d'une
équipe de bénévoles qui vient ici
presque quotidiennement pour fabriquer
des masques qui sont ensuite distribués
en priorité à un public ciblé comme les
sans abri ou les personnes âgées
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous
alors je veux vous donner du tissu à ma
super tu es méchant je voudrais
démarches pour moi et ma maman j'ai deux
cartes d'identité avec moi ce qu'on ait
des personnes âgées fragiles d'accord
avoir ma tête on reprend enfin envoyer
un peu plus âgé
une formation des valeurs des leçons
parce qu péri mais qu'ils avaient dans
sa collection on le voit bien d'ailleurs
cinq machines à coudre fournies par le
pôle paris à nîmes simon lefranc qui
voulaient se rendre utile quand
l'association a dû cesser toute activité
pour cause de confinement très
rapidement je me suis dit c'est dommage
alors que la pénurie de masques
commencent à ceux à se pointer de savoir
que dans le centre que je dirige il ya
du matériel pour faire des masques donc
les machines il ya éventuellement des
personnes qui faisait ses ateliers qui
aurait pu se rendre disponible et
rapidement ses montées sur pied cette
initiative de créer un espace
ou les personnes qui se manifestait pour
apporter une contribution en produisant
des masques ici ou chez elle
si on pouvait se retrouver nous on a
surtout apporté l'appui logistique
effectivement un petit peu d' expertise
avec quelques couturière qui sont dans
nos ateliers et une prof de couture qui
a pu venir
l'animatrice qui a pu venir donner
quelques conseils des petites mains
talentueuses qui repasse mesure coupe et
cousent sans relâche ou là depuis ce
matin je peux arrêter voyez je fais des
paquets de cases j'avais pas là on vient
de nous amener des nouveaux tissus donc
on y va on va essayer d'en d'éviter le
plus possible
moi au début c'est à dire j'y croyais
pas trop ce que cette épidémie je disais
aux gens aux ceux d'une grippe macha
puisqu'elle vraiment alors là j'ai
paniqué quand j'ai dit bien faut
vraiment agir tout de suite faut mettre
des masques et tout ça même si au début
il disait qu'il en fallait pas moins
dès le début j'ai voulu en faire pareil
les retraités et les temps libres et ça
permet de sortir de chez soi
certains jours les bénévoles fabrique
jusqu'à 100 masques ici et le maire
souhaite que cette activité se
poursuivre même après le dépouillement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui voulaient
faire quelque chose qui voulait aider
des voisins notamment les publics les
plus vulnérables et donc il me semblait
naturel c'est un peu la vision et d'une
mairie n'ont pas de tout faire mais
d'être un lieu où on rend possible pour
les gens de faire tant qu' il est
impératif de porter dès mars
je ne pense pas qu on s'arrêtera on
verra mais pour l'instant ça continue
anne hidalgo la maire de paris
recommande à tous les parisiens de
porter un masque dans la rue elle a
annoncé avoir commandé plus de 2
millions d'exemplaires qui devrait être
distribué dès la semaine prochaine
mais en attendant les habitants du 4e
arrondissement de paris viennent ici
régulièrement récupérer de quoi se
protéger